What is a shawl collar?
If you go to the dictionary,
by definition, it's a turned over collar
of a garment that combines with lapels
forming an unbroken curving line.
Now as knitters, we usually don't think
in terms of lapels, but we do
recognize the turned over collar part.
There are a lot of variations of this
style of sweater,
but I think we can agree that it's
a sweater, a pullover or cardigan
with an extended band that folds back,
forming a collar.
Let's look at them from a machine
knitter's point of view.
First, let's look at cardigans.
This is a shawl collar cardigan,
it's just a wide band running from the hem
up the front, around the neck, back
and down the other side to the other hem.
You could use any V-neck cardigan pattern
to knit this. Probably one
with a deeper V would work best.
There are some considerations. Since
the band folds over,
we need to knit a reversible fabric like
ribbing or garter stitch,
or we could knit a double layer band.
We can knit the band/collar
combination in two ways.
The first way would be a long,
skinny band knit in one piece going all
the way around the edge of the garment.
But traditionally, shawl collars are knit
in this direction, working
from the garment edge out.
As machine knitters we have
our needle bed limitation.
But we could knit the band in pieces
and then seam the pieces together.
Depending on the length of your sweater,
you might be able to strategically
position the seams at the center
back neck or the shoulder seams.
Or we could always just pick up
that edge and knit the band by hand.
A common variation of a shawl collar
cardigan includes a shaped cardigan band.
Now, if you're knitting that skinny band
lengthwise, you could shape as you're
knitting and increasewidth-wise
stitches to form the collar.
If you're knitting width-wise, you could
use short-row to form that collar.
So a shawl collar cardigan is pretty easy
to create without any changes
to a basic V-neck pattern.
Pull over shawl collars are very popular.
Again, it's just a band,
straight or shaped,
knit in a reversible pattern so that it
can fold over to form the collar.
The collar and band combination is set
into a V neck opening,
usually with a squared bottom edge.
There are many, many variations on this
design.
it's popular for small children because
the neck opening is large enough to go
over the head, but the collar comes
up close to the neck for warmth.
The secret to crafting a shawl collar
pullover is to make the garment neck
opening wide enough to accommodate
the collar and to make the neck depth
deep enough so the collar can fold over.
Looking through your machine knitter's
eyes, start examining shawl collar
sweaters and ready-to-wear
and hand knitting patterns.
You'll be amazed at how many different
versions you'll find based on a simple
band that folds over to form a collar.